à à
khi video này video này là cái gì nhé
đôi khi từ lâu lắm rồi chả nhớ không mấy
cái video này thì luôn à
Ừ
cái này về cái gì nhỉ
cô gái xem khác
thứ hai mới lên đi form of life
journalist Today I can see that weren't
meant to be
Person is
Jack shutter shots fifteen years and
turned the content Right now You
kitapida date to the voice points
[âm nhạc]
à à
có một câu hỏi khá hay một cái Mở chủ đề
là tiền với mấy bạn nữ ở
À hôm nay của tôi thật à Khá là ổn như
là
hơi dậy hơi sớm hơn mọi hôm vì hôm nay á
à Hôm nay được Nhà tôi có mời một bạn
sinh viên bạn thử các bạn ấy không đi
học đại học nhưng bạn đấy là họ họ cho
đầu tiên tôi dậy lập trình ý ông đấy hai
cái hai thì mở Hôm nay tôi mời lên công
ty tôi để mà thực tập
thì nói chung là trải nghiệm khác tốt
xứng đáng Đầu Tiên remix à
ở ngoài hôm nay sẽ tiếp tục phần 5.000
trong nhìn trông hơi chán rồi tí
nhưng mà tôi cho tôi sẽ sửa lại cái có
thể sửa lại cái hạt xác của từng bài
đăng để mấy ông biết được hoặc đặc biệt
mục lưu ý nên mới không biết được và Ừ
hôm đấy học những cái gì Chứ chứ nếu mà
nhìn qua cái sự đầy Đúng rồi phần 1 đến
phần 5 mãi chưa xong cái thêm nữa đừng
nó sửa xóa lắng nghe nỗi buồn cười không
ạ à
nhé anh Nha chia sẻ cuối buổi nó vẫn thú
vị hơn mà không ạ
ý thì cái đúng rồi cái video vừa rồi cái
video rồi mấy ông thấy đại khái nó dịch
kiểu dạng là và hai nó đang khối hận vì
đã lẽ cái điều đầy điều này nó đã là
phải làm 5 năm trước bạ thì
Ừ thì ông này thì bảo là sao mày không
suy nghĩ là cậu là mình mình vừa mình
vừa từ cũng từ tương lai quay lại quá
khứ rồi rồi bảo là mình làm cái điều này
tương lai có thể tương lai của 15 năm
sau chẳng ạ Đây
Ừ thì về có bạn thì mình vẫn bảo là
Ừ anh không ăn hận quá muộn đấy mình
được làm sớm hơn Vân cái cách suy nghĩ
đấy cái suy nghĩ khác hay Ở cửa là bạn ạ
khi bạn ân hận
đôi khi là bạn kiểu sợ là mình đã làm
cái gì quá muộn được nếu mà tương lai
mình coi lại
em nhắc nhở mình thì có khi đầy hứa mà
mình bỏ lỡ không ạ
Và tôi cũng thường ai suy nghĩ cậu Lạc
quan như thế khi mà nhìn một vấn đề gì
đó thì tiêu cực từ vẫn nghĩ hưởng là
quan nhiều hơn đứng ở tôi không thấy nỗi
là cửa ra quan đến nỗi không biết được
tiêu cực Có gì lập trình viên mình mình
phải nghĩ rất nhiều nhưng hợp nóng ạ
Nhưng mình phải luôn nghĩ đến trường hợp
à
thì mình phải luôn nghĩ trưởng trường
hợp bích Ừ nên thế Cuộc sống mà cuộc
sống vì tôi thấy thực ra là chẳng có cái
gì chắc chắn cả cuộc sống nó mình mình
sống mình sống tới tôi nhá đó là cô sống
có ý nghĩa Đó là thứ nhất là mình có hi
vọng mình có mình có tình cảm mình có
cảm xúc không phải một con người kia
không cảm xúc với cả con người hiểu Dạng
như nó bố đấy làm gì ngày nào làm đi làm
lại mình Cái thứ như cái máy mà không hề
thích cái điều mình làm hay là không hề
có cảm xúc vì về mọi thứ nó vô cảm lắm
và chán lắm đấy trải nghiệm thì tùy tùy
là người thích có nhiều trải nghiệm
riêng với anh em dân công nghệ như mình
thì ra là trải nghiệm nó khi không cần
phải nhất thiết phải kiểu dạm như nhiều
như nhiều người khác đi du lịch Sapa thế
giới gì gió khám phá mình khám phá nhiều
cái hôm qua có mã xã hội cũng một cái
khám phá mạnh nền tảng thứ khám phá Chi
lúc nó cũng là một cái
Ông Ngoại đừng có gò bó việc à người kia
ngày nào đang phải đi chơi mình thì cứ
ngồi đây ra thì đông yêu cuộc sống ở Nên
trải nghiệm nhiều cái những cái khác nữa
không phải mỗi ngành nghề ngành nghề của
chính mình mà nên giống như tôi ở nạn
tôi thở ra tôi thích kiểu có tạo thêm
nhiều mối quan hệ tôi sẽ gặp nhiều người
khác thì sẽ kiểu mình sẽ có góc nhìn
khác cũng như là mình được thêm trải
nghiệm mới họ dẫn mình đi những nơi mới
ở ạ vân vân
ờ ờ bà còn cái gì nhỉ
à mà cô sống thì đối với tôi hi vọng có
này còn niềm tin vào này là
và có tình cảm
đúng rồi và sống phải có ý nghĩa một tí
nữa thôi tôi
Ừ cái gọi là lý tưởng mục tiêu lý tưởng
nhất của tôi nói là tôi sẽ để lại một
cái gì đó không hẳn là cái di sản gì đó
nghe ghê gớm nhưng mà ít ra thì những
người mà biết đến mình
a nhớ nào số người biết đến mình không
nên à gọi là như nào
cho tôi bảo ấy thì tao tôi vẫn không hẳn
à muốn mình nổi tiếng lắm nhưng mà vẫn
muốn mình gọi là cũng có người biết đến
và có tầm ảnh hưởng gì đó một tâm gì gì
đó
và họ sẽ nhờ ấy mình với tự nhiên với
cách tốt rồi ngoại Chứ không phải là
cậu ông Ông này rồi toàn đi Loga chứ
không như thế à
chỉ có mình có dậy mình sẽ dạy các bạn à
7 cốt lên host lấy hộ thuộc ca thì dậy
tôi chỉ dạy về mặt cơ chế là chủ yếu chứ
để mà hướng dẫn chi tiết thì thuộc ra
thì với mỗi cái cái nôi mà cho bạn thuế
sinh hoặc cả VPS riêng thì nó lại có cơ
chế khác nhau nên thành ra là mấy ông đó
trước tôi thì mày ông bắt buộc phải mua
đúng hiểu ở cái Trang đấy thuê ở đúng
trong đấy Tôi không muốn quảng cáo bất
kỳ trang nào cả từ trước mày thôi không
biết cái quảng cáo gì cả nhưng mà lời
khuyên Lời khuyên ấy đó là
nghe lời khuyên đó là nếu mà Mấy ông
kiểu đã dành rồi thì ông có thể đưa nên
dùng bên nước ngoài thì nó có cái tốt
riêng bởi vì nó ổn định hay gì nó có uy
tín để tùy nhưng mà nếu mà ông kiểu dạng
nào ông vẫn còn mầm mời nhưng tôi cảnh ạ
Vẫn còn kiểu dạng cần Đôi khi phải cần
hỗ trợ hỗ trợ ở đây là hỗ trợ không
Ngoài việc hỗ trợ trong giờ hành chính
của mình Vân nó còn hỗ trợ Nó hiểu mình
nữa bởi vì nó không chơi bóp nó không
bắt mình hành động nhiều đúng không ạ
thì chơi thuế sinh ở Việt Nam được chúng
ta có để mua lâu dài thì tôi không chắc
được cái bên nào thực sự tốt đâu rồi
không biết dưới giống như thế nào
nhưng mà Mấy ông hiểu gì đâu Đó là ông ở
Dân công nghệ ông phải biết được là
chứ không phải biết đổ một sự thật đó là
đồ công nghệ hay mọi thứ Văn nó sẽ luôn
cần sự hỗ trợ luôn cần sự bảo hành do
Vân gì đó nhưng thứ nhất là không nên
ham dày Nếu mà mua màu gì đó nên uy tín
để mình đỡ kiểu ức chế thứ hai là nó cần
phải sự hỗ trợ gì đó đôi khi là bởi vì
mình đâu chọc Chán là sản phẩm nó sẽ
luôn Chạy ổn định luôn tốt không ạ Chắc
chắn là mình sẽ còn nhiều lúc cần hỗ trợ
đây Điền hình là tôi hồi trước tôi thuê
vô sinh ở trên hostinger được ạ Nó nó
trả lời Hồi mà tôi thuê host thì nó trả
lời bằng mà người thật nhưng mà bây giờ
tôi bỏ không thể hút đỡ chỉ thuê domaine
thôi thì nó trả lời bằng bóp Ừ nó khó ức
chế nhớ là hàng đợi lâu cái hợp giờ chả
boss thì chả giải quyết vấn đề đấy mình
là anh tưởng thế
Ừ nếu không hiểu ý tôi không thế thế nữa
à Tôi nghĩ là
cái về sự kiểu Chăm sóc khách hàng mình
phải mình phải cân nhắc đấy
a tiếp theo
Cho tôi xin phép bởi vì mấy buổi trước
nghỉ không được tâm sự không ai mình sẽ
tâm sự bù Tí à
Khứ hay đổi thì tương lai nó có thể thay
đổi và nó như nào Đấy nó giống kiểu
định lời định lý ông nội đúng không kiểu
quay lại giết ông nội thì sẽ không không
có mình chào đời mà không mình mà không
mình chậm không Mình chả đời không ai
giết cùng gặp Điệp lại đúng không Nhưng
mà định nhưng mà
ờ ờ đấy Thất Thuyết đấy là những cái
thuyết thôi chứ nó cũng chưa chắc là
chuẩn lắm Bởi vì a quá khứ đôi khi ông
biết được quá khứ hả ông biết tương lai
không thay đổi thì nó vạch cam với tương
lai mới nghĩa một tương lai song song
một cái kiểu
dùng từ nhá vẫn chưa trong phim mà phim
nó đưa theo những theo những cái giả
thuyết nó không trực đó nó không thể trẻ
ra đúng giờ thêm vừa đâu nha thì nó cũng
sẽ là các vũ trụ song song với Vân gì
đấy mở ra một cái mới
ừ ừ
đi Cái đấy hồi lính xa hả Tính sau
hostel Clow có ổn không
Mình hình như mình cũng chẳng biết được
là mình đang dùng nữa hút ở trí nhớ cũng
có la dù vậy
anh nói chung à
Mấy ông lời khuyên là mấy ông có nên
thuê thử vài tháng mà một năm trước ông
thùng ổn định tình tiếp ở bên đấy đúng
hoặc đào mấy ông cũng có định hẳn là lâu
dài lắm đâu nếu mà lâu dài Thực sự thì
đúng rồi Kiểu Thuê hẳn những thằng lớn
đấy mà rô này cái gì đó không ạ
u2a
mình bàn tí về cái này Hôm trước à
em có bạn nói với mình
Em nói cái vụ seo hết
Nếu bé uống chưa biết sẽ hết là gì cho
mẹ mày sao hết là sách tự lực không Hỏi
mỗi sách thử là không phải mỗi sách mà
sẽ là mà mà nói chung là nó cả những cái
bây giờ là những cả những cái
bài học đôi khi ở một cái gì đó Kiểu nó
sẽ khuyên mình đã lời khuyên mà nên như
nào nên như kia để cải thiện các thử
cuộc sống thử
anh ra đi à
an toàn bộ những cái lời này nó cũng khá
là Mỹ nhiều và nó khá là kiểu là quan
điểm cá nhân của một người nên thành nha
Tối nghĩa là
có giống ngựa Ông về ông nghe người khác
khuyên ông ngoại ứng nhưng nghe tôi
khuyên mà ông bà ạ bây giờ vậy ông
thường phụ không cần phải nghe hoàn toàn
không cảm thấy cái gì mình không không
phải là cái gì mình nghe được thì mình
nghe còn cái gì mình không nghe được
mình bỏ qua đó nhé Có nhiều người thấy
hơi bảo thủ Quá nhiêu cậu là cái gì đúng
theo ý mình nghe còn cái gì mà ngược với
mình thì không ngờ nghe thì ông sẽ bị
chỉ nghe
mọi thứ từ một chiều thì nó sẽ không cải
thiện được cái gì cả ông sẽ mãi là như
thế
Ừ
Thì ý tôi đó làm chỉ là ông Ông cảm thấy
ạ Ông cảm thấy là cậu nó đúng thì uống
nghe thôi
Ừ đúng ạ Cái cái sao hết này nó đôi khi
nó văn vở cực mấy ông thử xem rất nhiều
về khá văn vở để mà Cậu cho mình nghe bị
cuốn rồi toàn nó kiểu best seller rồi
kìa sách bán chạy nhất cho Vân nhiều
người từng Vân thì nó giống như ông Sách
Làm Giàu vậy
ô tô chảo tin và tôi chẳng ở động mạch
luôn đấy nhưng mà tôi đọc tôi biết được
trên mạng được đang rất nhiều hoa rồi
bóc các nó có rất nhiều người cái cùng
chung thể loại thì
hai thí nghiệm nghe hay đã đọc cái đấy
không sao nhưng mình vẫn phải tự đúc kết
ra rồi giống như tình tôi tình tôi là
con người Nó hơi bị cho Bảo Thụ đúng Nó
là kiểu dạng nó có chính kiến riêng đúng
nghĩa không phải là nghe người khác nói
xong rồi tôi sẽ gửi tin sái cổ người ta
không làm theo ý người ta mà tôi khuyên
mày ông cũng nên có cái chứng kiến lập
trường riêng như thế nào ạ Hãy giữ cái
đầu lạnh này không nên kiểu dạo nghe
người ta vẫn vỏ xong mà nghe Heo không ạ
kể cả tôi nói mấy ông cũng có thể với
ông thể phản biện lại tôi hoàn toàn
Thịnh khi Mấy ông không hẳn là là
kiểu chửi nhau này nó láo gì cả mà chỉ
đơn này góp vì nhau chứ tôi không đúng
trăm chẳng ai đúng hoàn toàn đây rồi
đúng không ạ Chúng ta đều được bình đẳng
như nhau
khi dùng từ bình đẳng đúng bởi vì kiểu
tôi không có tôi không quan tâm vợ ông
là kiểu không có tên giới tính này không
có tâm Độ tuổi này
anh kể cả Ông ở một đứa trẻ con nói với
tôi tôi vẫn nghe trực ông cách tôi 30
tuổi tôi nghe kể cả ông không học trong
cái ngành của tôi tôi vẫn sẽ nghe chứ
không biết khi ở tôi sẽ kiểu dặn à Nó là
kiểu Dạ không nghe ai cả Không ạ
Thế mình nhớ đó là tôi nghe nghe một
chuyện giống như lời của thầy cho từng
dậy rồi phải biết làm ngay kiếm cái khác
để biết cái bộ thủ mình là đúng đấy nghe
là việc nghe nhưng mình vẫn sẽ làm theo
Đôi khi mình vẫn sẽ phải giữ kiên định
và có lập trường của mình mình chỉ lắng
nghe thêm để xem là mình đúng hay là sai
thôi
tiếp Tâm sự nói cái này đi bắt đầu buổi
học thì
Ừ tôi thấy à học công nghệ thông tin
ngay tại thời điểm hiện tại ngoài việc
là tôi thường hay tự sướng với mấy ông
là học công nghệ thông tin là
nó không Nhà nó không nhà nhưng nó có
nhiều cái hay nhất là ai ví dụ nắng mưa
thôi Được rồi trong nhà hả nhãn hôm nay
hôm nay lâu lắm rồi cô mới lên công ty
rồi cảm thấy là tự nhiên hôm nay mình
dậy sớm lên chỗ ngồi cũng hiểu đi đi lại
lại cũng lười mệt hướng cho tự nhiên cảm
thấy à mọi khi mình ngồi nhà thờ là vui
thế
à mình làm xong rồi làm bìa lương thì
vẫn đủ sống hôm nay em Nếu không biết
đâu Mấy hôm nay tôi mua linh tinh những
cái gì đâu May mà kiểu may mà mình gấu
mình chọn ngày này mình có cái mức lương
rồi ổn để mình có thể như thế không thì
không biết à
à à
a tiếp theo tôi cảm thấy da thú vị ở
thời điểm hiện tại đó là nhiều người làm
xong đối với họ những công việc hiện tại
của họ nó là công việc chứ không đem lại
cho họ đam mê lắm Em hãy ra khi họ về
nhà thì họ sẽ phải kiếm đứa khác để mà
giải trí hay ở cũng vừa Vân Họ tìm cái
thứ tách biệt với công việc của họ để mà
thư giãn con à
à Còn với tôi và đa số anh em mà tôi
quen thì lại áp dụng chính cái mà mình
đang băng hiểu biết cái vốn hiểu biết
mình để áp dụng vào trong chính cuộc
sống của họ tiền Hình như là anh chán
gần đây chia sẻ link để mà lấy được
lấy được video từ JAV gì về HD là ạ ấy
một cái hồi trước tôi làm con chắt bóp
để làm mình gái mà để tải Ngày Về chợ
hoa cả Bây giờ tôi đang làm hộp bây giờ
ngay bể thời điểm hiện tại tôi đang có
tận 3 4 cái pack 1 cái trang hội cho tôi
nó là trang để mà ạ chia sẻ chia sẻ nhạc
đi một nhà hàng thì bây giờ tôi tôi làm
để mà nhập toàn bộ những cái danh sách
toàn bộ những cái món của tôi ăn vào và
tôi đánh giá chấm điểm nó để điểm và kém
với địa chỉ để bảo vệ sau tôi sẽ ấn nút
ngày nó sẽ ngẫu nhiên ra khỏi quán bất
kỳ để cao thứ thứ đấy một cái rất đơn
giản anh em nào ở đây giờ học đến những
mày để làm được nó hẳn là đều làm được
không ạ Mà mấy ông thể áp dụng rất nhiều
cái Bây giờ tôi đi đâu tao nhìn cái gì
cậu thấy tôi thể áp dụng công nghệ được
vào để mà giải quyết được cuộc sống tốt
hơn thì cái đấy là cái mà tôi cảm thấy
nó rất là hay so với hiện đại so với
ngành khác
ở nhiều ngành khác thì ông học xong thì
ông không áp dụng được cuộc sống đa dạng
và nhiều như thế
Ê hồi trước thì tôi từng nói mấy ông ở
ước mơ của tôi à trở thành nhà ba Hậu
điên à trở thành cậu Ba học của nhà phân
minh gì đó
Nhưng mà thực ra là bạn Nhà phân minh ở
Việt Nam mà không được sử dụng nó lắm
cái hợp vừa phải học quá nhiều rồi tiến
sĩ có thứ giáo sư thứ bị khóa tài thị
cái lý thuyết và nó không thực tế
A và vẫn cả là tôi kém nữa nó thằng ông
phan minh cái gì đó khá tốn kém thế bây
giờ tự nhiên khi mà tôi học xong ngành
Công nghệ pin này tôi cứ có ý tưởng đâu
có nhiều ý tưởng Công Thì tôi cứ
anh cứ bắt tay vào làm đây Chỉ sợ tôi
thiếu thời gian thôi nhưng mà may may là
tôi cũng gặp được nhiều anh em
anh cũng có một vài anh em cũng Cùng
chung suy nghĩ Và thậm chí ý bé nghe bài
cũng không nghĩ ra được ý tưởng Đấy hẳn
Cũng không nghĩ ý tưởng phong phú rồi để
tôi cứ ngồi nghĩ ra ý tưởng là tôi giao
mấy ông ấy đều người làm ngồi làm cùng
không phải tôi dao mấy ông ấy Tôi thường
nữa Nói chung anh em cùng hưởng làm da
tôi sẽ khi mà tôi xong những thể cô sẽ
kể xong tôi sẽ chia sẻ với ông mày mày
ông có thể cùng hưởng cùng tôi nghĩa tô
mấy ông cùng đóng góp nữa thứ càng tốt
đóng góp có thể không phải đóng góp cốt
mà nó có ý tưởng thêm bổ sung bình an
không ạ Đấy em một cái rất là hay cho
mình tự mình làm những cái thứ để thứ
nhất ở phụ hộ chính mình thời Phục vụ
được cho cộng đồng đây
vì nó có thể ở rất là nhỏ nó chẳng có gì
to tát cả nhưng mà nhưng mà nhưng cái
đấy chất xám mà thật chỉ có thể
nhiều người thì vẫn nghĩ ở toàn bộ những
thấy những cái đấy có thể kinh doanh Tôi
không nghĩ mình cái điều đấy Vậy thì anh
hóa Tôi muốn chia sẻ thôi muốn chia sẻ
cho cộng đồng thôi nó hiểu cho
ok Nói chung mà vừa rồi tâm sự thôi
tôi mua cái gì á
ừ ừ
tôi đi siêu thị tôi Tôi muốn mua bim mẹ
không cho về hội nghèo nàn không thôi về
đi mua siêu thị chỉ mua đủ đồ để dài
thôi chồng đừng mua gì khác hay ra khi
và lớn lên đời mình mình làm bao tiền có
tiền đấy có cổng đống tiền người xong
rồi cậu ở
ăn trộm chỉ thích vào siêu thị ở không
biết mua gì nhưng mà nói chuyện kiểu
muốn muốn thôi hãy rồi thích thì thì mua
sản
chị Hai mà
anh nói chung là hôm nay tôi một đống
thứ tôi không không biết kiểu sẽ dùng
dùng kiểu như nào hết đi mua
tốt nghiệp được không
Cái Linh Mời ông vào bên đấy ridley
Scott đi Tôi có cái linh linh đề tài đồ
án này để mấy ông thảm hại tham khảo với
nhá Nếu nó ra để dựa vào để làm những
cái đồ án tốt nghiệp thì nó nên là những
cái bài toán về quản trị những cái quản
lý gì đó
này nhá Bây giờ thì
bây giờ thì
đi học thôi
À
hôm hôm hôm nay mình sẽ giải quyết cả
cái tính đa hình này
nhé nhất là
có bạn hỏi Và thậm chí ở hội trước mình
từng thắc mắc đó là thứ nhất ở trên mạng
trên các diễn đàn công nghệ rồi có quá
nhiều sách
anh đúng không kết hợp việc là quá nhiều
thông tin chính thức cần phải đọc phần
cần phải học vấn Ừ thì có nên học hết
tất cả được mấy ông khuyên ở đây nó là
không từ từ thôi Bởi vì và thận chế phải
học chọn lọc bởi vì sách có rất nhiều
nhưng mà tôi thấy có rất nhiều sách nó
bị đến huyết quá kết hợp việc nó thậm
chí nó dịch ám ảnh tiếng Việt nó nó nắp
nó còn khó hiểu hơn hãy nên hãy nên kiểu
đối với tôi đối với tôi nhé đó là tôi
Ừ Tôi không phải là con người à thôi em
ngồi thích đọc sách và nói
lễ hội hội chợ thế nào rồi bây giờ thì
mọc nhiều trên mạng rồi là đọc sách lấy
nhưng mà đổi tôi thì nó bị lý thiệt quá
mà ông chỉ đọc một cái lý thuyết đấy
thôi mà không áp dụng ấy thì ông dễ quên
nói trâu là nó không đọng lại được cái
gì đó Ông đọc đọc như kiểu nước quay ấy
hiểu sao ông ấy nên là tôi nghĩ là
ờ ờ đi đừng cái thì ông đọc cái việc là
kết hợp hợp với việc là ông phải thực
hành nhiều trong ngày ngày như thế chứ
ông không nên đọc quá nhiều nó bị của
quá tải kiến thức cũng như là quá như
thứ cần nhớ kiểu định sẽ Quê
và
đặc biệt là đừng có nên đọc những quyển
sách dịch nó bị thấy nó làm cho mình đọc
nó còn khó chịu hơn và nói thật tiếp
theo Ừ anh có bạn hỏi có vài bạn thực là
mấy ông đang xem cái này thì chắc là mấy
ông đều đang theo cái lớp và chuyên sâu
rồi nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng cũng có vài bạn yếu cũng thỉnh
thoảng Xem của tôi sao bạn ơi yếu ở đây
là bạn ấy chỉ đơn giản là chậm hơn cho
các bạn khác bạn vẫn muốn học thì bạn
lấy kiểu dặn là có thể cẩu không gọi là
nhá tiếp thu tiếng phu không nhanh có
thể dùng tư thế hoặc có thể tôi không
Không khiến nó bà ấy tiếp vui nhanh được
bác Vân thì bạn để bảo tôi kèm thêm ở
gấp nào đó không gì đó thì tôi hiện tại
tôi đang chẳng có mở lớp nào và tôi cũng
không ý định là tôi sẽ mở lớp nào
nào thêm vì thức dậy nhiều quá thì nó về
công nhận cũng hơi tốn thời gian mà cũng
hơi chán
Ê mày điện thoại đi chơi chứ tôi không
nghề cho sáng ngồi cốt rồi
tối cắm mất dạy không Cuộc sống
thì nhưng mà còn lớp chả phía chắc là
không không ý định kiểu sẽ mở lớp sạc
như cả nếu mà đương nhiên là đến tháng
10 như tôi đã bảo mấy ông này chắc là
thằng mười tôi sẽ nói chuyện ít hơn
không biết được hứa hẹn như thế nào bởi
tôi sẽ còn là định sang bên FPT dậy ở
nhà tôi Nguyễn Trãi cổ ít nhất ít nhất
là phải xong cải cái đồ ăn á cái đồn web
môi giới này đã trước khi mà trước khi
mà sang bên đấy tôi sẽ cố xong chưa mượt
29 Vợ bận rồi tháng 9 là tôi đã chuẩn bị
cho cái buổi offline như tim committee
rồi
a Tiếp theo là cái tiện ích này cuối
cuối buổi thôi chia sẻ nhé tiếp theo đó
là
trên cái trên tiếp hát của tôi từ tôi
quay học tối không phải ở để mấy ông
theo dõi nhé không có tầm mấy cái lắm
thì chuyến hát của tôi em có một cái
Zippo Zippo web 10 người bán hàng này
hồi trước ngày sinh nhật lắm nhưng mà
gái xinh chọn lọc của tôi bây giờ nó hơi
Tôi không tôi chả tôi chuẩn bị gỡ để tôi
làm hàng cái mới từ xa bây giờ có mỗi
ngày web môi giới gà này thì nó là mã
nguồn mở thì khái niệm ngoại mão mão mở
Nó là cái gì
à à
cho
mở đúng mới eight nó gì nó kiểu ông hoàn
toàn thể đem về ông sử dụng Và thậm chí
uống thể đem về để ông làm kinh lạc được
với Nhưng mà ông vẫn sẽ phải giữ cái
mạng mở ra ông không này đem về và ông
biến thành mã nguồn đóng nữa Chỉ dùng
một đi riêng ông này cái thứ nhất thứ
hai đó là
ở đó là
Ừ ông không được kiểu à Ông vẫn phải tôn
trọng quyền tác giả thì ông vẫn thấy
phải dẫn đến cái gốc ấy đấy khái niệm 10
đi Tôi nhớ không ngờ được Tôi không biết
là tôi nhớ chứ sao đọc nó lắm một đại
khái nó mạnh hơn mà người béo hòa tan đề
đóng góp kết hợp việc là ông thể kéo
dạng nào đây còn non về pháp về để mở
Ông làm cái của riêng không cũng được
không sao
tôi nghĩ em bảo ông Nếu mà thấy hay mấy
ông ấy đóng góp ý nghĩa là sửa ôtô cái
giao diện hạ thế à
Còn bây giờ bắt đầu dạy nha
của anh được không ở tôi nghe nhạc xem
phim
có khá nhiều để mà tôi cảm thấy ở kiểu
tôi không sợ tiếng Anh đấy Cái đầu tiên
và tôi thích cái nền văn hóa của bên đấy
đấy đấy Cái ổ mình không bị áp cảm với
nói thì mình sẽ hiểu sẽ sẵn sàng đón
nhận nó lấy cái đầu tiên rồi và và vào
lẫn cả là kiểu ông phải tiếp xúc cũng
tương đối nhiều thì ông mới học tiếng
Anh lên nhanh và không nhớ luôn cái ông
không ngại với vấn đề đấy con bé ở đối
với ngành này Thực ra thì chỉ cần đọc
tài liệu các thứ thứ gặp nhiều kiểu định
sẽ hiểu lá là được
vào nhé á
nhỉ
lại nhé á
à à
sao nói đây ok
từ trước mình làm clip vẫn đang làm giỏi
crash trong xấu nhá đại này giao diện nó
bị vỡ bị xấu
Ừ thế này mà cho hát rồi xem ha rồi sẽ
chê trang web đều
Ờ Ờ
mình cho mình làm đến đâu nhỉ Mình đang
xuống đến cái đoạn à
anh đăng tôi tạm tắt hết trong Ai đã
giả sử có Company các thứ thứ ngoại
quyết giờ đây không sao về này để xem
nhé xem nó quý ở đây đăng trả về là rỗng
hi vọng để xem Tại sao đầu tiên mình sẽ
xem đường dẫn là api language này sẽ mở
file ipa lên này
trả về à ở đây mình thấy là khi mình
không gõ Tìm kiếm cái gì thì thành ra là
không trả về cái cái gì đó không ạ thì
mình sẽ bắt ở đây là trong trường hợp mà
nếu có nếu có Và nếu có gì đó thì mình
mới mình mới kiểu à
à à
Ừ nếu có gì đó thì mình mới trả mình mấy
kiểu thêm điều kiện như ai cũng không
thì mình mặc định trở về hành hạ thế
mình sẽ là ít
Anh đi quét hát Và nếu có đúng không
gì đấy
Ừ nếu có thì mình sẽ như thế này
khi con còn không thì mình sẽ mặc định
trả về là chuyển ạ
ca nhạc chuông em
cái này phi tơ này nó sẽ trả về chua
Phone Mà thì mặc định mình sẽ luôn đúng
chẳng
bí
ẩn này đó sẽ ra toàn bộ đúng ạ Cái chưa
thì chọn hoặc là mình sẽ gõ tìm kiếm như
này nạn thế
Ừ ok không ạ
cái này lại lỗi về cái bát à
Thì tại sao mà
ở đây mặc định năng lỗi đường dẫn này à
ở mấy cái này khó chịu nghỉ để tôi xin
phép tôi xin cái một tí rồi Xóa sư của
đi Đỡ đỡ bị rồi
ừ ừ
mình khó chịu nha à
Đa số con gái made này nữa
ừ ừ
ở V.League ở đây khi gặp ăn ít này à
ở Avatar
Lương Sơn
ở Avatar này
có
chấm gì bây giờ nha
ở nhà ông để tìm ở trong cụ thể trong
cái thư mục quy xuộc này sẽ ra
Ừ Ok ấn ở đây Open như này nha này
ở xã đây này
à à
không còn gì nữa đúng không tiếp theo
cái này là tôi nhớ không lầm là
có liên quan đến nữa à
hai iPhone or của share
xin phép thế tối chưa Hôm trước chưa
chèn hình cái phone và mình sẽ lấy cái
thư mục phone để mà cậu nó sẽ không báo
lỗi gì nữa đây hyper này
xe Honda mình sẽ phải copy những cái à
Ừ lấy luôn cả thư mục cô này đi
có một hồn và cho bao
mục đích này
hai iPhone Mình có rồi mày nghỉ ở quê
mình có rồi chứ nhỉ
I Phone
bộ set Phone
ở
lớp 2 có mày nghỉ
ẩm thực
anh làm sao
khi mở đường dẫn này sao
anh không tìm thấy
ý nghĩa đường dẫn của thằng này đang có
vấn đề chứ không phải là chị đã xem nhé
a Google Zenfone
nụ hôn
à hay là phone mình có chữ S nhé
anh đúng không iPhone thì cậu cho F
họ đậu xanh
Tôi sửa lại đây nha
a-pdf này nó phải nói ra nhỉ Cậu nhỉ
It
is a
I Phone
các em ạ
để để cho làm tiện để mình sẽ leo cách à
Ừ anh
thì post hình
anh sex
đồng dẫn này nó không chuẩn nó phải án
sách access người đừng dẫn kiểu như thế
này nhưng nó đang bị nó không tìm thấy
cái hướng dẫn xém này đúng thì không
Ừ cái này mình sẽ để thư mục phone phải
nằm trong thư mục xét trong trường hợp
này nó mới đủ
Ừ ừ chứ nạn được nghỉ nha
anh
em mình sửa wifi nhà
không đúng vai chứ May mà thành iPhone
này có rồi bỏ qua mệt quá
kệ kệ tính sao à
là gì nhỉ
thì tại sao hài bây giờ nó không lên nhỉ
Đợi tí nhé Hôm trước mình sửa cái đó tự
nhiên giờ nó không lên hàng này rồi Ồ
mình có Lost đ
một ngày sẽ loạt this
ex5
các bạn đi chích ở đây
a parent
anh hỏi thằng ngày
a resolution
cho nó chấm
xổ số kon solo slot ở đời Pháp
anh em đừng dẫn là như thế nào đã
xu hướng dẫn nấu hình giờ đang rỗng hay
gió rồi Đúng rồi Đừng giận đang ăn defy
select City A Đồng hồ đúng rồi hôm trước
mình cho cái ở đây một cái sexet nhưng
mà ở trên này chưa có ai
Anh karaoke
ok rồi
à à
Anh xóa cái này phát này đi ok
bây giờ xử tôi sẽ thêm mà hôm nay anh sẽ
làm thêm cái A
mọi người thường đi hát sao fullface Thì
sao không bỏ qua xe đi
thêm một bài đăng nha hôm nay làm tử tế
thì một bài đăng này khi mình là sử mình
class đúng không
Ừ nó xảy ra ra ra mấy cái như này không
Mình sẽ
anh khi men kết phát nữa này thì nó sẽ
xếp lại hộ mình mình sẽ lừa lại cái con
chuyển đúng không đâu
a Company Company mình gửi lại Company
đây rồi không ạ Khi mà mình thành công
việc mình lưu lại Company này thì mình
sẽ phải à ẩn cái form đi đúng không ạ ẩn
cái pho mua đồ đi ừ
khi phải tách hai cái này ra
cái trò cũng hơi dị tím mình sẽ gọi
thằng này sao mình hay bây giờ được vào
rùa sẽ có lúc của mình không hại không
hay hài
sắp xít thì Hà đi ở trong ạ
anh ở đây mình mình sẽ kiểm tra mình sẽ
weaphone trở về trong điều kiện dysport
trở về là phát xít thì mình mới ẩn đi
nhé Còn không thì mình sẽ in ra cái lỗi
đấy
à à
về bản chất thế này tôi sẽ tống vào
trong một cái phong trần đi
nhà báo phóng sinh là
ờ ờ sâu Alo ạ
Có ai đi
À mà đây sẽ là truyền Alo à như thế này
ở đây
từ ngày tôi sẽ ký kết lên cho cá rô đây
ra
ở đây concinna đây sẽ là à à Vsip bootcd
thứ ngày
ok à
à à
chết cả
Ừ dạo này nó mất trách truyền vào
anh khóc như thế là chả tôi vẫn sẽ giữ
nguyên này đi
Alo miss
cho tỷ lệ đi Để tôi sẽ cho nó aromas như
này à
à à
khi truyền vào từng thằng chuyên vào
từng tham để xem nhé Để tôi xem đã
Ừ ok ok
sau đó thì tôi sẽ copy kể cái này
anh xuống đây vậy trong trường hợp thằng
này Alo ở như này thì mình sẽ
ở Sapporo là Euro như thế này chuyển
thẳng vào nó là dạng kiểu mặt chuyển
thẳng vào đây mình Ninja chỗ như này à
đi Này mình sẽ chuyển hàng ngày vào như
này ok Còn nếu trong trường hợp là cái
thằng ở trên này nếu mà không thành công
này thì mình cũng sẽ đầy lỗi mình sẽ in
ra mình sẽ lấy từ cái thằng xuất ít này
như trong trường hợp này thì mới Ông
thấy ra cái Magic cái main Chip mà của
thằng Bon này trở về Ế nó sẽ chỉ là nó
chỉ là chuỗi thôi chứ nó không phải là
mày thằng này truyền Bà là Mạc có thằng
này chưa Nó chuỗi Tôi sẽ để nó là trong
mạng trông như thế này được cái hiểu đêm
à
Ừ ông thì ok
à à
nó hơi khó chịu một tí
tôi sẽ gọi đến nữa vừa nãy gọi đến hàng
nào để mà thêm nhỉ ngợi ý với ai đúng
không vì ai thêm Company không
I am in à
amin này thêm đúng không Thi Ở đây là sử
gia sử nhé tôi có mặc định cho in về một
cái lỗi thì gọi đi như này
lỗi rồi ạ nghĩa Cả hai đều in trở về cái
alo đúng không thôi béo tôi thử tạo một
cái hàng mới thì ông xem nhé
em bảo gì đấy
ở những này chẳng hạn không ạ
anh ấy à
Sửa mình cứ tạm cho thêm tặng cho thêm
gì cả anh Granny
thì nó sẽ trả về cái lỗi rồi đây thi à
Ừ cái á sau Euro của mình ngoài việc
hiển thị ra tôi nghĩ là mình sẽ chơi một
cái notify để mà in ra để lỗi ở ở dưới ở
bên dưới để cho mình dễ nhìn đi notify
hôm trước là tôi ôm về chưa nha Nhớ chưa
đúng không Trông notify về cho bé ông nó
ngồi xem nhé
a notify
A2 pơ này như nó có sẵn một cái về
notify có xử xử rồi sẽ xem em ạ
thế
này để thông báo có một cái hay này hoàn
toàn notify này sợ dùng knotify của nó
là nó sẽ in ra kiểu như này
soi kèo ngày thường hay là sẽ cậu bên
ở bên phải như thế mình sẽ chèn thêm một
cái như thế này ờ
ở hai nội dung cái á tốt
mình sẽ ăn cho new Để xem nó dùng cái
thư viện gì cho mình trẻ nên về mình sẽ
dùng cái top này thì phải đúng không
nếu như không cần nhưng không cần nhờ
trong thằng này có sẵn rồi vậy tôi thấy
nó khai báo Nó kiểu như này thì mình có
thằng Toàn thể dùng được tôi thử luôn
nhỉ thử luôn nó nóng nó mặc định là
Trang ạ vừa vào tôi cho hẳn Swift như
này sẽ em được không nha
à à
cần chèn thêm lẽ bản chất là thằng à
hyper là tích hợp sẵn nó khai báo sẵn
một cái thử cái này trong mấy ông rồi
đấy thì đương nhiên là đương nhiên là
mình sẽ phải cậu bị sửa lại một tí thì
mày Ông thấy ở đây á
sau khi bấm vào
ở đây có cái phải để mô mày nghỉ học cái
để mồi đây xem thử đi mua nhé
ờ ờ
Ừ mình đây có
Ê bà sắp xít à
anh sắp xếp
giá sắp xít ở đây nè
ở
đây đúng không cái bản chất là nó sẽ là
C này werden này sau đó thì có thêm cái
xúc xích ở quấy và Austin dai nó thử như
thế này này để nó tầm day tôi sẽ lấy của
báo từng ra này
à
thì mình truyền vào những cái gì mình sẽ
truyền vài cái thôi Ngày đang cần phải
chuyển đủ cả bác cao có lô Tao không
thích
ờ ờ
bengal và được Nếu thế thì mình chỉ cần
sửa lại ở đây đó là
Em sắp xít này
có màu Không sót một đẹp lắm nhỉ
ờ ờ
Ừ ông Alo là sắp xít này cái thứ được
không ạ
này
Ừ mai sexy ok ok
à à
thì mình sẽ Minh Minh có thể thông báo
thành công thì bảo thất bại
Ừ tôi thường là tôi sẽ viết thêm một cái
file hay g-suite ở trong này đặt tên cho
nó là file hấp ơi em ạ
thế này hepl
gì chấm z mình sẽ luôn cho em cái file
này vào đấy hepl Hồi đấy cho từng làm
rồi ấy cả đấy thì tôi sẽ có cái hàm
thì nó sẽ có cái hàm ở đây trong trường
hợp cái đoạn này nó sẽ chuyển miễn ship
vào như này
khi nãy sau đây sẽ ra là notify sắp xếp
Đà Nẵng thế nó gửi cho ông ạ đây tôi sẽ
gửi kanchan cái này vào trong như này là
xong đương nhiên là tôi sẽ muốn Four
Seasons nó sẽ là ở
có xin mà sẽ Oxy sinh
ừ ừ
nội thất tân rai lúc nhìn này
ở
đó ngày này mà Đây mình sẽ có một cái là
một tay fire Oh chẳng hạn thế
ở
đây sẽ đội hai cái này Alo thôi
thử thứ chả gì cả để bây giờ cung vẫn
lần mình gọi đến hàng ngày thì mình sẽ
chỉ cần à gọi đấy nó như thế này
kể chuyện em Trinh ở trong mạng được
Anh nói như thế này Ok chưa
Ê mèo tôi tôi hoàn toàn hệ tôi chạy thử
trong xem nha sẽ đây là lỗi rồi ạ Cái
tính năng này cái gì đấy
a Wind
à À cái file kia file được loa rồi mình
sẽ thử từ Liêu cách đi chạy lại xem ở đó
để lỗi Ok chưa
màn hình tôi chia mấy cái kia sang màn
hình bánh kia đấy Nếu không thấy rồi nếu
không có thấy tôi đang ngồi đọc sách rồi
đúng không ạ
chú ý nghĩa vừa rồi sẽ in ra được cái
kiểu tóc tự như thế nó notify có hai
ngoại thằng này tích hợp sẵn cái tosses
ở trong ngài pha yep chấm min của nó có
tích hợp rồi
à à
ạ Bạn ấy là mỗi khi mà Ông sắp xếp cái
như này thì ông cũng nên in của bạn
thành công nhé in là một cái file xap
xít để mà ông in thông báo là thế Mình
Công ơi gì đó
Ừ
tôi sẽ cho đây mặc định là
ở đây phôi là chồng đi
ạ Bây giờ sửa mấy ông không không truyền
thông tin thì vào ý già thông báo thành
công cho người dùng người dùng vui ở
được rồi còn cả như thế
mỗi khi mà sắp xít này anh sẽ gọi đến
hàm số sít nhỏ như thế này chúng ta lại
chai này
cái cái này có rồi cho hẳn cái chưa có
đi Ẩn clip này rồi tôi chọn cái gì Gió
ngày anh quyết này
Anh bảo lỗi lỗi rồi nhưng mà nó không in
thông báo lỗi để xem nhé Làm sao nhé sau
Euro ở đây con xô ở đây nun từ âm Jack
nó thanh trả về
Ừ tí lại sao đây là luôn nhỉ iPhone Euro
spoliation của mình
Ừ để tôi thử con xô con số lóc hài đã
ừ ừ
bạn trong trường hợp này nó lại là mít
chứ không phải là
cách tải Euro còn như hôm trước thì để
mẹ ông làm trường hợp này cho nó chuẩn
thì ông có thể chơi trò này nghĩa là ông
ông một trong hai cái này được nghĩa là
sẽ như này à
à à
à mà nếu mà thầy có ít
từ ngày có mình sẽ truyền Euro ở như thế
này đó
Thứ hai là mình sẽ như thế Tôi sẽ có mặc
định cho Euro trên này như này đi Hãy
bảo alo Đấy Let's Grow này cho mình
chuyển và như này eo ở đây mình sẽ
truyền vào là
anh em sẽ đẩy miên ship thôi
sẽ bằng
áo sơ mi sis
Ô thế cái này không phải là mạnh nhỉ đỡ
thì đợi gì nhé Thằng này càng làm anh
cũng chưa có vay thôi mà một thằng đấy
nó sẽ là kiểu như này
rồi
thì tại sao này
ở xưởng dress which make up
à à
ở đây mình lên đội kẻ hát tác mà kiểu
desk Ừ mình đang học về Online
ừ ừ
em bị lỗi xem nào sẽ đổ lỗi này mít Euro
được vô ích
anh alo thứ hai nó sẽ là mạng với mình
đó là mạng rồi
a a max tôi mạnh nữa rồi rồi Hiện tại
sao không được đoạn này
Em in a tinh thần kinh tăng
Ừ hai cái mảnh liền
dù bé mê thủy ông có thể cho trò là ông
đi thẳng ra lỗi luôn được nghỉ không cần
phải làm à
họ lập tạp như này
anh nói gì à in lỗi Còn nếu không thì
không phải chơi trò nó còn này nó cậu
nhìn người khác nhìn cốt của ông người
chả hiểu gì cả Nói về như này
a cho thai vào trong cái mảnh nữa được
Ừ đúng nhỉ Thằng thầy có hỗ trợ mạng
nhiều chiều mày nhá cũng hình như không
thì như thế này không hỗ trợ mà nhưng
chưa Đó ra suýt hội chợ mảnh đá chiều
Tưởng nhớ ai
Em không biết được không rồi nhé
Anh nhớ là Speed phải công hội chợ mảnh
đá chiều Giống nhờ pp Nhưng mà thực
ừ ừ
thấy thông báo lỗi này xong rồi như thế
này
phải làm đúng kiểu đối phó
Tôi không muốn sửa lại cái Hàn này còn
không là miếng sẽ bắt trường và kiểm tra
xem nó làm ảnh hay không Nếu nó không
phải là mạnh thì ông ông in kết quả luôn
chứ phải làm kiểu như này thằng khác
ngồi đọc cốt của ông
Hai con điên
đấy tôi tôi đã gợi ý ông rất nhiều cái
thật là để gợi ý Cốt nó không được nó cố
tồi ấy là không tốt đâu Thế hôm ấy ông
sửa lại thì ông sẽ phải kiểm tra ít like
này không kiểm tra ít IIS này thì kiểm
tra xem mà nó phải ở đây không sau đó
thì niệm Nếu nó không phải thì ông sẽ
Ừ ông chạy in thằng luôn thì nó tốt hơn
này à
I eat Android thằng ạ ngoại
Ừ nếu nó làm mà mình có đoạn này chẳng
hạn thế còn không thì em ấy
vì nó có làm dạo này luôn thì nó kết quả
luôn như thế
truyền vào là cả chuỗi giảm ạ đều chấp
nhận được
anh ạ
cái chung nữa nhỉ
ừ ừ
à À rồi lỗi tôi nói tôi là tốt Hãy Gọi
cho má
vừa rồi đấy Alo
em chuyển Alo trong ngày
i go
kìa thầy có về mà
chị sẽ nhảy xuống đây
khi sex
sao đây nó không Alo ở đây
chị đã nhỉ
cái email lỗi đấy
anh rảnh thật ra à
không thể cậu dạng là cái khó bỏ qua
được
à à
chuỗi rồi
khi trở về đây là mít như thế này
anh em restore message Đúng rồi nhỉ ờ ờ
ừ ừ
thế này nhỉ
có ai ngờ nó lại nhờ cái chai cá rồi bảo
sao vẫn nhiều cho các Ở Đây Rồi
ăn xoài cát đây nó cũng nhảy vào lỗi rồi
hai ngày liên quan đến được mà
ờ ờ
khác
À mà đấy à
tôi như không tin được file ngoài không
tìm được file này công ty file nó lỗi
nếu thế Nếu thế thì mày ông bắt phải bắt
luôn lại trường hợp này nếu mà có thì
truyền báo không bị bỏ qua mình sẽ là
Mourinho
cha mẹ ông nhớ gỗ truyền đầu nào nghĩa
là nếu nó là luôn ý
Ừ thì bỏ qua kệ nó
ở nhà sẽ không bị lỗi hơn nữa
Công việc tốt không chuyển file ảnh mà
khi đó nó sẽ mắc định nó không lưu lại
gì cả nó sẽ nhờ đến xuống lỗi rồi Mình
in ra rồi ok ok
còn mình hóa ra vẫn tệ không ạ Mình tích
được cái tệ đấy Ok Bây giờ vẫn tốn quá
nhiều thời gian rồi bây giờ mình đã làm
xong vụ giết ông ạ quyết Company Sau đó
mình sẽ làm gì mình sẽ cậu âm đi gái
bí ẩn đi cày ẩn đi cái form này
Ừ đi mà quét thành công như này bị sợn
thứ không hẳn là ẩn đi mà tôi đang định
là nó sẽ điều hướng sang tra thành công
cái gì đó
Ừ đúng nhỉ Đầu tiên là mình làm theo lô
rách mình sẽ up for này để mà trả về kết
quả lỗi nếu có này trả lời các lữ thứ
à Còn nếu thành công thì mình sẽ điều
hướng sang Cái trang mình sẽ điều hướng
sang cậu Xin Chào Thành Công Lý
ừ ừ
Ừ vậy nha
À hôm nay thành công này sex ít đấy
à à
Ừ đợi tí hàng ngày thành công thì
đây đúng không Không Tao đi đây này
form đây à Ok Ok mình vẫn sẽ là kiểu thì
sẽ Windows chấm ducfashion
a dress
thì mình sẽ điều hướng để ra mình sẽ
điều hướng đến router
em thật sự thế là kiểu sẽ là admin post
Ê thằng nặng thế nhưng đáng nói chung và
khi mà thêm hình cong xong hết rồi ngoại
mình sẽ điều hướng đến cái đường Vinh
này mình đâu has cũng nghỉ lâu không làm
này quên xử rồi
vì thế
Uh cho nó bằng cái gì đó thì nó sẽ nhảy
đến rồi nhỉ Nhớ thế
mày á
24.com
chồng ơi
để xe mà đi xem nào ô
ấn vào đây là mình cứ tạm tắt hài á tạm
tắt này đi ạ
thì mình sẽ Tân ạ Mình chưa Mình mình
chưa xử lý các nhiệm vụ thêm thêm thành
công
này
dự án tạo thêm với thành công này sắp
xít ok rồi đúng không ạ sau đó thì mình
sẽ
không hiển thị cái pho vừa rồi gửi cho
mình xem nhé
bí ẩn này sẽ không nhìn thấy pho vừa rồi
Ừ đấy Nó sẽ hiển thị ra cậu bắt buộc
phải truyền cái gì gió ngay đâu ạ
hai cái bờ nó lại đây Quan trọng mình sẽ
lại toàn bộ tất cả đúng này Đấy hôm nay
mình làm đã lưu mà anh mới làm được cái
lưu mình ghê ăn Min này chị sẽ nhớ đến
cái Lưu ai
à Hôm trước mình nó chỉ request một vài
cái thôi
Mình sẽ lưu Mình cứ trai khác tôi thường
hay làm đó vẫn luôn xe cát đây mình sẽ
Return sắp xít và phê ấy sẽ Return ở đây
là một cái xấu xí tẩu ngoạn một cái
Return Pro về không biết được nhỡ đâu
trong trong cốt của mấy ông có vấn đề gì
đó giống như vừa nãy mình chưa bắt được
các trường hợp mình cứ trai cáp mọi
trường hợp đây trái các ở đây nó sẽ có
khái niệm thằng rally là sẽ phân biệt
hai khái niệm đó là trái các exception
và trái cát à ạ sau Apple ông dùng
exception kiểu ngày cũng được
a
section cửa nhà
hình ảnh
ngày ông sẽ có thể được một trong hai
một cái là một cái Assassin 2 thôi Apple
hay hàng ngày nó khác gì nhau Tôi thường
Ai sẽ giúp thích dùng thôi bồ Tại sao
bởi vì à ếch sắp sần thì đương nhiên ấy
sẽ chuẩn là lại những cái lỗi Liên quan
lỗ thích nó kiểu làm cốt đang chạy giờ
nó có vấn đề gì đó
chứ không phải lỗi liên quan đến chính
tả nỗi không nên con hàng cú pháp nó lỗi
lô gic đấy thì nó sẽ nhảy vào sân còn
thôi bồ thôi bồ nó chứa tất cả cả ép sân
và cả lỗi về mặt logic nữa ông thể trao
cái thôi bồ của gram thì mày ông để so
sánh nó với cái sân Đông sẽ thấy khác
những cái gì ở lại méo thể tra xong đâu
ạ
anh nói chung hợp với cá nhân tôi Tôi
rất thích dùng thôi bộ hơn Nó bắt được
mọi trường hợp có thể về lỗi của mình
thay vì mỗi xin nó chỉ có người mỗi mặt
lôgic thôi
Ảnh à
khi bé đầu tiên là mình bắt được toàn bộ
những cái này không ạ có body này
cho nên em chẳng hạn bằng máy quét
vợ ý rồi nên hãy có nó cũng hơi vất vả
hơn à language which lên là sẽ dạng mà
ra thực tế Thế là tôi thích để nó là
thêm chữ s để hiểu nó xuống nhiều thường
là mấy ông mình sau đó Tên Biến thì
không nên thêm chữ s hiểu nó xuống nhiều
nhé
ừ ừ
này nữa nó như thế này tiếp theo nữa là
City này chích này mình cái này Ok này
file tại đây Tại sao mình đã thêm chữ s
Có ai có một không ạ
anh phải ở đây lại sao lại có khách hàng
ngày nhé
Ừ đợi tí
à à
à mình có chuyện em phải đâu nhỉ
sữa chua đây
thế nào nhỉ
áo phao Mình làm gì có ai đâu
anh alo
từ hôm nay có vẻ là nó constant nó ghi
đè lên gì vậy
à à
tôi có trên iPhone
vậy Number 2 thồ
à à
a City II
City 20 cái thử kia bỏ qua đi mình cứ
đầu tiên có như nay đã có con đi này
mình sẽ xử lý từng hạng mục đi mình với
thằng Company này thì mình sẽ lấy
companyid từ
thì mình sẽ kiểm tra tạo mới nó rồi ấy
sẽ ra Company này bằng Company bộ đồ
mình sẽ đó
cho con đi
đi mua đồ này sau đó mình sẽ
A gọi đến a
phát egreat
à à
thế này và mình sẽ tạo mới nếu mà chưa
có cái nêm đấy
tôi sẽ truyền thêm vào như này Ừ anh sẽ
là a Company rough Night
chế tạo mới cho tôi một cái cục Quân Y
đó ngoại
cái hàng này tác dụng như thế
ừ ừ
và sau đó thì mình một lại ID của nó bởi
vì mấy ông nhớ về vụ là mình sẽ lấy mình
cần lưu lại trong này là mình sẽ có cũng
có đi đúng không Mình sẽ
ra nhận Đây là trong trường hợp mà mình
truyền
nhà mình có truyền Company
lên không nhỉ
a Company mình hình ngựa để chống được
mày ạ để chống được người dùng cho
trường hợp để chống Vì sao
à à
khi dùng trường hợp để trống để tạm à
đi
tạm bỏ qua đúng không Thì mình sẽ đây là
ít
mình với tạ
companyid nhân ái
nó thôi Nhìn thấy sẽ không phải đi ID
số tiếp theo trang web mình chuyển lên
cho nó hết mình chuyển lên thì mình sẽ
lưu lại vào trong nhà
anh mất language Cái này nó là hướng ba
hết đa hình mà hôm trước tôi đang định
nói đó chỉ là ông sẽ tạo ra một cái mua
đồ này có mua đồ rồi bản chất là nó sẽ
là theo dạng mà có khái niệm của thằng
Idol Thằng thằng là arial hay là thằng
nào nó quy ước cái tên mà nói sẽ là sẽ
tượng nó sẽ quy ước kiểu như này
Ừ anh sẽ quy ước là cái bảng trung gian
nó sẽ khái niệm tên là file flash thì
chị ạ nghĩa là bạn trung gian nghĩa nó
bản chất là nó chúng ra nữa hai thằng và
nó không có khóa chính hoàn toàn mà nó
sẽ có hoa chính là
vậy tôi tôi sẽ tìm lắm
Nếu như không có hỗ trợ tìm cái sim mày
nhưng không có cái cái bảng mà chúng gia
này sẽ có khóa chính là bản chất là nó
sẽ là
hai cụt khoa ngoại liên quan đến hai bạn
kia đấy thì mình sẽ
cái đa hình quan trọng cái đá hình mà
tôi sẽ lưu lại đây là là nó là kiểu kiểu
gì không ạ Tôi sẽ ở nhà bây giờ tôi sẽ
tạo à
Ơ cái thằng mua đồ này đã Vios thấy bộ
Facebook mua đồ rồi đó
anh ơi
Ừ rồi tôi bị sao
em tắt đi vậy
ở bên này có nhỉ
em dùng tạm cái này nhé CD sang này web
này
ô môi giới này
ờ ờ
Anh alec
nhà mình có mua đồ là
chị sẽ đặt tên ở đây sẽ là áp language
ừ ừ
Khi
mình mở mua lên thôi
ở ngoài bạn chất là mình sẽ có phát huy
thì đây cả mình sẽ là thời gian này còn
có cả mic file ghost xong rồi nó kế thừa
paved con nhưng mà thực tế nhá Tôi từng
tìm hiểu chán chê thằng quay vơ đổi hồi
nào vào năm nó bị hạn chế và cái đấy cái
quay vô giá hồi đó chưa phổ biến lắm Tôi
không nhớ ban đầu như nhau nhưng nói
chung là nó đúng là nó có một thằng
riêng hoặc virus nhờ tôi thấy nhiều
người khuyên Hồi đấy ngồi đây nhá đó
nhiều bởi vì nó chưa phổ biến nó có chứa
nhiều hà mà mình người ta bảo cứ dùng để
mua đồ in họ thực bản chất nó cũng không
khác nhau mấy thế là bây giờ tôi tạm
thùng Model còn là còn không thì để thế
thì tôi tôi xem cho tôi thử xem lại nữa
ở Facebook xem có nhầm
The Best English cái
khi con đi-xnây em bé ông thể khá ít
thông tin về Viber luôn Không biết bây
giờ thế nào đây
à à
mà không thấy
ô
mai với nhé
e-business
khi nói về cây thua thằng ngày 20 kế
thừa ráng mua đồ nghe thôi Tôi nghĩ là
tạm dừng mua đồ đi
đâu nhà mình sẽ ghi đè lại cái tên bạn
với tiền bạc của mình nó sẽ khác
về tiền bạc đúng nhỉ a public gì vậy
Ừ cái bộ là em check out
à Còn nếu mà ông không đi để phiên bản
thì nó sẽ thêm chữ s Đằng cuối nó Hiếu ạ
tiếp theo là gì nhỉ à
thì mình sẽ không có mình có mình không
có tham xem rồi
đó là mình sẽ không có cả
inputman là tự động tăng
a tiếp theo nữa đó là ở đây mình không
thể là cái cột khóa chính của nó nó là
hai cụt thì đối với thằng áo len đổi
thằng level nhé Thì không có khái niệm
là
ý là hack hack cụt là một khóa chính mà
Nó là kiểu bảng nào cũng phải cần có một
ID để khỏi chính Nên là hồi để tôi phải
chén thêm một cái Pocket nữa
để cho nó là nó là monty bồ Chrome là
khóa chính nếu tạm tôi sẽ tặng chưa chưa
động đến vụ đấy Ở đây tôi sẽ gửi đơn
giản ngay đây là mình sẽ có thuê bồ
không ạ cổ tích cực
lúc thì vô tích cực thì ông
khi họ thằng Mỹ là cái trò này nhé
anh nói thế là cái này có cái công khai
được có cái không không thấy nấu phải
thế
ở đây sẽ có là
Anh check ID ông ạ
anh
đúng không Tự nhiên của tôi vì anh tiếng
Việt mấy chưa ạ
tiếng chim hót chim đầu
a sparkling ăn thì có chùm tôi đúng
không ở đây à
à à
anh em
ý của tôi biến tiếng Việt có chữ ngờ
anh sex du học Anh
đi
đấy
em thủy tinh Hitech máy chưa
ừ ừ
tôi không thích màu này lắm nên thôi có
đỡ đau mắt còn không đúng không Nhưng
màu đen này con nhận trong sấu thật
language ID đúng không biết
Có ai đi phẩm chứa nhiều nhiều ông này
còn không tạo cái thằng này có thằng
Vios không cần tạo luôn đã có vài ông
làm thế
hay này truyền Thay vào trong này Ok Ok
Bây giờ mình sẽ
anh ở đây bài toán đó là mình phải tạo
thằng phốt trước sau đó mình mới tại
thằng ông chết này cho mình sẽ ghi dám
thẻ ID của thằng boss đấy với với từng
Hằng này một Nếu hiểu rồi em ạ anh cả
năm Mỗi ngày tôi sẽ để sau đây mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ có Toàn bộđóng thông tin ở
đây đúng ạ Mình sẽ cần là
em
lấy toàn bộ mấy cái thông tin đấy ok
iPhone Smart các thứ thứ ngoan thì mình
ở đây mình sẽ có reports thôi sẽ gọi
post cho mình sẽ gọi clip
á nhon
Ừ thì ở đây nếu mà
Khi bữa trước mình làm thì mình sẽ lấy
vài đích thực là chỉ là
Đó là những cái truyền lên mà đã được ra
hết nhưng mà không thể có rất nhiều cái
Company làm cái cột của Manny làm việc
con language không ạ thì mình và nam
giới có file của bạn thì mình sẽ ở đây
là chị only thôi chỉ lấy một vài cái
mình muốn lấy
anh như này
em My
em không được à trọng với chồng à
chợ hoa nhỉ
à mà only chắc không cần vài biết rồi và
đất qua bước này được kiện đi à
thì mình sẽ lấy ý cột mà Eco City này
chẳng hạn đúng không
ở kiếp này Cái gì đó gọi lấy từ bên này
thôi
Ừ để tôi tạo một cái tắt ngang cho mấy
ông nhá Tôi sẽ chỉ bị phong cách này
lười như tôi nhá nó Tôi sẽ mở router này
web này Hôm trước tạm cái test đây đúng
không Mình sẽ
xe tải ghét
a z gì nhỉ có lúm nêm
Thay bồ tao à
ừ ừ
Em thử nhé
Ừ ok này
thì nó sẽ ra ngay Ẩm Thực ra tôi không
cần cái này tôi sẽ cần cái thằng này mới
đúng
à à
ảnh Copy lại về
giàu ngày két thôi không phải nhớ đơn
bởi cái gì sừng nó nhảy kép
ID không truyền này ngủ rồi đi không
truyền này Company có rồi này gặp thầy
thổ có rồi này đi chi tiêu với Mốc này
pin á quân Sea Sorry này từ qua mình xài
tốt là top athleta toàn bộ đoạn này sẽ
đi nào Okay chúng ta có những này lắc
này bỏ qua flash thì mình dùng Smart
table để mà làm rồi à
anh
không lắc này
khi mình chuyển Smart vào
ừ ừ
mình vẫn phải có
cho mày không bảo lỗi rồi mày không tin
nữa đi thử hỏi nhưng mà thôi cứ xóa đi
cho đo thể hiện truy nghiệp
thấy suốt câu chuyện này Hôm trước trẻ
vào sạc
ừ ừ
a Smart option
ca nhạc không cần không cần
ờ ờ ờ Ok rồi
em
về mình sẽ chỉ cần à à môi quen quyển
copy một loạt cái này vào trong thằng bé
được
à à
Tôi cho mày xem
U21 Apple nghĩa mình còn chưa Lưu lại ở
trong nhà ở trong này thì phải
Lê Hiếu
Ừ đấy mình làm
thì tại sao mình làm thiếu cái pho mai
được nghỉ tí một Apple mình không có này
ipad2 mình không có này có lẽ mình làm
chỗ chiếc bóp này nhỉ
à à Ừ chán à
anh Hiếu nha à
anh remote Oppo ba con cái gì nhỉ Xem
nốt nhé
Ừ Ừ Còn mỗi đi Mốt Apple status bỏ qua
sao top mặc định mình sẽ cho xa tất là
bao nhiêu rồi mặc định cho chào tất là
bằng là
ờ ờ không rồi à nhưng ở đây với điều
kiện admin amin thêm vào thì ạ thì sao
tốt nó sẽ lên là bằng mụn chả thế
cái Khi mà mình thêm giống như này anh
sẽ mặc định là xa tất nó sẽ là bằng mấy
khi là là
ăn bim hãy chẳng ăn thế mặc định mà mình
sẽ lưu lại không cần để lưu lại trong
mai mình không xử lý về toàn đấy mà xử
lý kế toán ở đây không
còn gì nhỉ
a lô a pin
em kiểm tra xem nó được ghi mới không
Cái này thì ở Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ làm bắt
riêng ra nghĩa có thêm là ăn sổ đỏ thì
mình sẽ ghi âm sau
- 1 Apple có thể cho thêm đó nha
Ừ cái bồ
Ê hồi trước là có bạn nào gợi ý cái từ
này hay lắm Tôi khuyên trừ rồi đó là
Office
thì nó sẽ có những trạng thái là Office
Remote
Khi mà mình sẽ check móc và hai lần đấy
thì mình bắt được cụ thể nó sẽ là cái gì
đóng ngoặc
mình sẽ là tôi sẽ lại phải xem lại hyper
hyper
vì nó có cái vụ trước
à à
vào để Trạch cho nó hay
I just know baby yeah snowing
khi họ chết nữa hai đây là police pic
này
I thought đây tôi sẽ lấy cái rét nâu
à à
chú ý định
ao á
Ồ vãi
à à
em gõ tay lại nha
ừ ừ
anh dinh dưỡng đây
xe lửa
em
đi từ bên này xa không đủ tử vi Song
Long Panda
áo vest lại
anh bị mất
Ừ được rồi
có gì
à à
ở Vienna festo mà có vấn đề
ờ
ờ remote I
đầu cho cho phép đi ta ta
I quýt
ừ ừ
thật
label này
How to
bộ remote
cho
appa online.buh
anh Bằng
à à
I Guess
ừ ừ
từ lâu
xe xôi thằng này sẽ copy
lại mình đâu cần copy cái này đợi tính
sau nhé này nó sẽ thêm một cái nữa thế
này cạnh nhau thì sẽ là cũng xấu xít
nghi ngờ
nên màu sắc tí cho nó sẽ là kiểu đạn như
dưới đây đi Fendi
info mà sẽ là Office
à à
nhỉ remote mình chết nâu và một cái là
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
31 nhận nâu
em làm cái sẽ là
chờ đợi tí nhà được cái tính nhà
ừ ừ
A Gọi điện lâu nó và phải Pô kê ở đây
mình sẽ thêm cái nữa là à
Ừ đấy mình làm là cho is part time thì
chú phone thôi là
ha ha ha
Cũng là tree Snow
nhá nên mà nó là
I eat specimen
à à
các ngôi sao
họ
đậu xanh gợi ý
31 này ai đi là
từ
ngày có về copy ở chết rồi xem nha
copy rồi
tủ bếp
sinh viên hài chế độ mạng
à à
Ừ có gì
ừ ừ
à à
trẻ em sơ sinh
Vì sao tự nhiên của tôi một là cái bị
biến này thành này rồi
à à
cho chồng cái này nên như thế nào nhỉ
ở dưới hằng ngày đi cho nó dưới vào ngày
đi
Ê bà đi Thế thì sẽ là
sửa lại cái cái cái nút này đi
à à
bộ remote
xin lỗi mốt
anh em remote
ở đây là
ô ô fish
Anh
Việt Thu Thôi được
a piece
a tiếp theo là haha mũi
chị xem Park Hye mi
ừ ừ
à à
những ngày sắp xếp ngày info
Âm Nhạc
hai iPhone đi
ừ ừ
này ghi nhiều chữ Hỏa trong này nó bị
tràn quá thì ông sẽ phải sửa lại cái CS
có thằng em tí ông sẽ cho máy cày with
nó tăng lên nhé
ở tòa 100 này chọn ô 110 đi ạ sau đó thì
sao
Ừ kệ Apple poster này không phải xê dịch
nó ra
ý dĩ vãng
có ai làm này thôi
U60 không chấp nhận
thứ ngày
Ừ chị vãi ờ ờ
em
copy này
à à
khi sex
ô
cửa sổ Thôi kệ
a cho hai cạnh nhau nữa
nhà hàng Hà Nội mốt Thằng nô phí để cho
cách nhau này
không đầu nó buồn cười thế đẹp mà chắc
thế
Ừ tôi không chia diện với ông không quên
thắc mắc gì không quên ý kiến này đây cả
Anh
ở trong hai cái cộng với nhau trong nó
vẫn cân mả bị nổi không bị lỗi
anh em thử điện thoại nha
này bỏ qua đi
khoa học rửa chảo lên lên cái trang đăng
bài code mà
Quốc để mà
lại đi mà không lên điện thoại để đăng
bài đâu
chơi cái gì lúc cháu lên chơi đấy
có những những đứa Chí Phèo khác giỏi
nhảy vào mà làm à
có ai trong trường hợp mà chưa có 10 con
đi nào chọn không ạ khi nêm bình tĩnh
Tôi chưa Cho nên này nên thằng này bạn
chắc là hai này nó mà mình sẽ
nghĩa mình sẽ có và lu thằng này
chị sẽ Peru nó
U22 điều hòa remote Apple đúng không ạ
an apple
anh em để hiểu nó mạnh đi tiếp theo là
thằng là mình sẽ có và luôn nó anh không
ba lô nó sẽ chỉ có on-off đấy thì ông sẽ
alo cụ thể là remote một cái value sẽ là
ô ô fish ngày
anh ơi
à à
một điều chắc thì ông có thể không thì
ông sẽ chỉ cần
dù cho có nè Chu cũng được tôi tớ thích
cậu để xem nhé để xem
Ở họ có một à Nói chung là phải có
tôi chưa Cái này hay hơn tôi chưa cái
hại hay hơn truyền thẳng có bao nhiêu
này nhanh
ở điểm gì để tôi sẽ thử trong em xem nhé
ở
thời gian thử nhé xem
ở đây
áo bóng chuyền lên ông thầy ông truyện
tranh Diệu cũng chưa lên trưởng ai on
hay off 2120 gì giờ không quan trọng nó
có giá trị ở đây tức là mình mình đang
truyền anh có giá trị ở đây là mình mình
hiểu được ạ Nó là cái rồi đấy được 2
kiểm tra xem có ghê có cái remote không
có cái Office không không hiểu không
chịu ngày nữa Spare time i
anh ấn vào thì nó sẽ nhảy xong cái này
gì không thì cái này remote Apple
sparkling thì cái remote Apple này đoạn
này mình bắt đầu mình ngồi sửa lại nhá
request này thì quen này không ạ
Ừ mình đang Bình đang
nhà
mình cần ốp toàn bộ hàng ngày
Ừ nó sau đó tôi xin phép xóa này đi này
Xóa Hay hay đi Này tại sao Vì
Anh ơi Tạm tống thằng này lên trên cùng
đi
ạ sau đó đây tôi có thằng e đây tại
Company and như này cơ truyền cái thi
này vào trong file đó rồi Tiếp theo là
mình sẽ là Nguyễn Thị sau đây nhé
và tiếp theo đó là mình là có cái mi mốt
vừa rồi đó ngon mình sẽ bắt theo remote
đây bồ không ạ
31 people mình sẽ phải trong trong này
mình nên có nhé để cái remote để đâu nhỉ
ở đây sẽ có
khi mua Apple mình là
cho người đi bộ cũng được ở đây
hình ảnh như này
a Tiếp theo là cái á
Anh không quan trọng lắm nhưng mà mình
vẫn nên khai báo và và nó thực ra nó
không quan trọng với kiểu dữ liệu luôn
có thể để chống lại như thế này rồi à
I Only Only status status thì mình mặc
định là mình à
từ khóa rồi này ờ
ừ ừ
còn gì nhỉ
à chích
VinMart Black ash có thể truyền lên ok
rồi nằm bữa recon ok ok đấy Thì bây giờ
mình sẽ bắt là ạ
Bây giờ mình mới bắt là kiểu nếu nếu mà
có cái key này đông ạ thì mình sẽ như
nào ít
I could
ở đầu tiên thì mình sẽ cơ ừ ừ
truyền hát cái Mai mốt thế bồi đã cho
mình rồi bắt tiếp là
Đợi thì đợi thì tí nhá
Ý mình là chưa khai báo i5 cho trường
hợp này nhỉ Gửi năm tháng ngày chưa Nghỉ
trưa ở i5 Ừ đúng rồi mình trước 75
trường hợp này ờ ờ
chị xem ad5 đi
a cho mình dễ hiểu make này i5 này sẽ
làm poster à a remote thấy bồ
à à
a public I
ô ô sin và dai mặc định và chị Thúy mốc
này
A là
anh đi để lưu lại số mà
anh alo bị lừa chữa cũng chưa từng yêu
tôi bảo lưu lại số dễ mà
thì mình nên lưu lại xóm trường hợp này
mình không cần phải như vậy chứ cũng
trường là mày đó cặp bác hạ thế Farm nó
lưu lại là kiểu
cho trẻ bú lần nữa mày nghỉ
ờ ờ
the morning định lưu lại của bốn lần
thôi tôi tí rồi phải sửa ở 2 cột mày mất
không thể hai con này dữ liệu Nó kiểu nó
không chuẩn về sau mình sửa lại được
nhưng mình lưu giờ bắt buộc phải chọn
đi tiếp nào Office này
phim hài The remote olive và Office for
lease nhé
ở nhà à
thì mình sẽ là
Anh Đài năm mới
hai
chưa bằng ấy nhỉ
ai ngờ mỗi bài sửa bài cho mẹ không
tất cả đi không không trợ tất cả đi đúng
không Nghĩa là
nghĩa là bắt buộc phải có đi
xe máy quay
thì bố phải có
em làm gì chuyện tất cả hai không ạ Ừ
1102 Ok cần
Em nhớ là phải có một cái một cái này
hoặc cả một cái này học cả hai ông ngoại
Ok rồi đấy tôi thể lưu lại này nó không
báo lỗi nữa này ạ
à à
bây giờ mình sẽ là
A11 thuê bộ nhà chẳng hạn bằng
anh đi
dự báo lỗi nhỉ tiếp theo là I eat
ờ ờ MT
xe máy
21 people
vì thế mà không có thằng này anh Nếu có
ra ngày
nào cho dễ nhé hai trường nào trước đi à
Cả hai đều đâu có đi đừng có bắt theo cả
hai trường hợp tôi có thì mình sẽ có III
xe tải
bộ remote Apple
à à
anh bằng sẽ bằng này
ở lại dinamik dám chỉ ở nó có cả hai mà
ông ạ khi con eo đây eo ít ở đây là
à mà chỉ có mỗi thằng này thôi
ừ ừ
Lê
Hiếu sẽ là
chị sẽ là
Office còn đi nó ba chục
anh không ạ
Anh chuyển cái này vào là xong
ex2 It's part time
Ừ chị ạ
thì mình chỉ cần kiểm tra nếu có
à à
Ừ nếu có parttime này
thì mình sẽ cho là
tùy ông ấy ông thích làm i5 được hoặc là
mấy ông cố định luôn là 10 rồi mày cũng
sẽ hiểu bởi vì nó ít Nó là kiểu boolean
và nó tên cột họ rõ ràng em thật là mấy
cũng không cần để đi 5 lần thì cả ông ấy
ông ấy quy ước thẳng luôn nhưng lại được
sau đó ông sẽ để iPhone đây sẽ là à
này là gì nhỉ
Ừ dạo này nhớ Sai Dạo này không phải ít
parttime Nó là kiểu campanha mấy kiểu có
thể làm
à à Thế Giới Hồi đấy Mình cũng định chia
trường hợp với vai cậu chỉ được phép Chị
tuyển thì tiền parttime á nhon một cái
nó sẽ là
thì mình sẽ là cậu chị chuyển bác tham
này một cái là mà thôi không nghĩ Phúc
ta vẫn cứ nghĩ là không cần ở phức tạp
ấy nghĩ em chưa
a cho phép Pasteur mày không thôi
Anh hiểu tí hơn nó campanha màu vị hơn
mày Spare time thế này nữa
Anh tên Đây là campanha mà nóng campell
đi
ý kiến bác hàm nhé
ở đây nếu mà có thì mà phải cho cái bán
hàng một mà mình sẽ cho nó với phô Tôi
sửa lại tên cột luôn nhá Ừ
i m này enter
à à
khi enter mình sẽ có sửa hay cột là
remote p.bồ
A và
I eat Spare time and each part time
Anh
tên cột có biết danh chả đậu xanh Bloom
em inbox table
Ơ con này
a boss
Em có cô ta
mà Mấy ông muốn làm cái cô đơn giản thì
ông sẽ thẳng nhà luôn
à à
Anh tên ngày thứ ba rất dài rất nhiều
người khó chịu với cái tên này nhưng mà
nhớ là đặt tên cho nó tránh chủng thứ
hai là nhìn tên nó thể đoán được về sau
tôi rất hay Tôi rất hay tìm lại những
cái migration nào mà có nhắc đến cái tên
là có sửa lên cái cột đấy thì có thể rất
dễ tìm người ông hiểu gì cho ông cậu tôi
sẽ vào thẳng thêm cái cột tên là ha mà
nó gõ gà Nó ra cả thế nào đã bởi vì nhé
bởi vì nhé Bây giờ tôi gõ rõ ràng tôi gõ
Michael sheen là là poster bồ nhé ngon
đúng không đấy xấu rồi tôi vào đây tôi
xem đấy tôi tôi thấy ở đây có một mà ít
parttime đúng không chán thế đúng không
Đấy sau đó Bây giờ tôi bảo là tầm bậy cơ
thể lại tên cột lại campuses này ạ sẽ
thắc mắc Và cái file My xin nào Đã đổi
cái ít phank parttime chẳng hạn thế Thế
mấy ông cha thời fire xin lỗi đi mà ở
trong database này sao mà bị ông mở cái
này lên đó đây là đang có mỗi tí bảng
mỗi file nhưng mẫu một chiếc khác biệt
rồi ông ạ Ông có thể chế Cách thứ hai
của ông trách thì ông sẽ lại phải gõ là
can parttime nha à
Sao ông tìm trong ạ đích Chân Ni sao tìm
trong cái ra tao thấy bồ của mấy cái
chuyện này nhưng vẫn chưa đủ tiện bằng
cái được là ông gõ ship nhà rồi Ông tìm
nữa chính tên file luôn đúng không ạ Đấy
do tôi đã tên file có vẻ rất là ra nhà
nhưng mà ạ Nó về sau dễ tìm mà ông hình
trong cái gì có lý do đó cả 10 người ta
người ta yêu cầu ông đặt tên file làm gì
trọng như thế cứ cho ông tạo phải có mấy
chân luôn là được cái để tạo hình file
không ạ
mấy ông mấy ông bây giờ mà lười về sau
mày không sẽ bị nhược điểm mà nó cái
khái niệm là nợ phải phải trả nộ cốt
phải trả bằng cốt Thế làm chị bị ông
lười thì về sau tông cốt sẽ rất là mệt
ông sẽ rất là đau đầu rất là nặng hiểu
không Cái bài toán phải trả để rất là
mệt đấy không được bạn rồi ông nên mấy
cái này ông ấy rất cẩn thận trông thấy
có vài đoạn mà tôi tôi phải nhắc nhở nhà
với thì tôi từng trải không ạ Chưa mấy
ôm Junio thì ông đặt tên biến PC ngoạn
có cái gì đâu
chị sẽ cho Trinh này á không nhỉ Ừ mình
nhà
bà Kiểu integer
à à
ạ sau đó thì
trên này
Ừ tôi không biết là còn zin em có đâu mà
đây trước hay sau rồi đoạn này đổi được
không ngờ không vì Nỡ gọi như thế con
không mình lại tại một thằng hẳn Thắng
nữa cứ nên như thế này cơ
nhỉ
Khi mà mình sẽ có đi vô đi
ừ ừ
ăn kem
Mập Nam
à à
ở bên em có Luna from to ok ok
Em còn ở đấy tiếp là mình sẽ có mấy mốt
Apple
có bồ mình sẽ lạnh tôi cho
à à
mình đã đổi thành
Em đổi tên sai vãi để j-10 j-11
Anh ở Huế một lời bố mẹ nó
em nói chứ quan hơn tí cho rùa nó không
Ừ nó cũng sai chính tả ăn chứ
- for boy đi đổi điều khiển dữ liệu mà
ok ok trong ngày được không quan tâm
Thắng đào nữa
sẽ thử nhà chắc là được
à à
Ừ anh em ạ
i i
ừ ừ
bao lần này không Ok Ok rồi
ai sẽ để để thế thì mày Ông bà đây ông
flash thì nó sẽ gọi ít tên cột lại cho
ông chó cho
hang Seo Ok rồi
để còn báo lỗi gì nữa chính tả cái đi
xin lỗi
I
started and They are struck hết rồi hết
rồi đấy Xong rồi đấy tôi thử D cái này
không xem nhé
nó dễ mà
đi học Ba tôi vừa làm cho mùa dạng Mấy
ông lâu thế tôi cốt bình thường em
ừ ừ
khi thiếu dấu phẩy và
anh ạ
chú vịt này để mà gửi đầy lại nè à À
đúng rồi nó biết mình đổi lại tên thành
Towers rồi
đang ở đâu đó
thì tại sao đi
a mắt
thế này à
ta0 cơ chọn bị khùng đi Đồng nghĩa này
nó ngon đúng không có mặc định cho cả
hai nhá Ấn này
có ai
a City dist này không có không có quần
xi một này đấy
khi mua lại bộ ba này
lưu lại hết xin học sẽ nó nó chỉ việc
led là xong
a lot of people don't have deviluke
cài
đặt tên đây ở Thái Tổ
Ừ ok ok
mình để cho chồng đi
ca nhạc Ai Khổ Vì
tôi nhớ ở dưới tôi có nhắc vụ thay thổ
ID Thái hồ mà thôi để ID có lý do cản
kéo gì tôi biết là sửa đây tôi lại phải
sữa dưới tôi sợ đấy thôi còn không sửa
ra bệnh được
Tại sao này
à à
bí ẩn này
áo lót Thái khô hôm trước hình như mình
để nó Thạch hổ ngon ạ
ở lại
bài đăng lên chuẩn chưa nhé ạ
em có Hồ Chí Minh city Bình Chánh ok rồi
này thấy không chị ngay một làng snack
là thứ chị Ok rồi Company ID mặc định
lên rồi mình mình chọn cái triệu rúp mà
đấy ngon chưa
u-ear
em thử cái thử cái bảo là
anh ở đây có khái niệm nữa đó là ông có
thể biến cái son này thành con update
luôn cũng được nghĩa là ngay lúc này ông
già sự Ông nợ ẩn class ông ông Tự nghiêm
sửa thêm vài thông tin nữa nhiều người
dùng như thế đấy sửa và thông tin nữa
cặp thôi chết nó bấm nhầm thêm mà đáng
lẽ tao phải cậu Điền sơ sửa gì đấy thôi
ạ đang Ấn nút này sẽ nó sẽ ra vừa update
of clear mà dựa theo cái à
a mắt chẳng hạn hay dựa làm cái gì đó
anh phong cách riêng lạc được những cách
riêng và nhíu mày toán nó đỡ phức tạp
hơn đỡ sửa cột nhiều nhưng mà nó bị lặp
lại cốt cũng khá là nhiều
tùy mấy ông tôi sẽ làm nốt cái vụ là bây
giờ có bài đăng nào ạ Mình sẽ có tốt rồi
đây này à
đây nhưng lại Black đang với cái này
mình sẽ lưu lại 22 Đây là kiểu in chị sẽ
tạo cái i5
anh ở đây sẽ là
Office Project language
năm rồi nhỉ
ừ ừ
thế này
các bạn chất là tôi đây tôi sẽ lưu lại
là pháp nick này
Austin này đây mình sẽ có boss cho anh ạ
bằng một chả thế
anh ở đây tôi sẽ là
trái phối này
ở Đà Lạt đều từ ngay đi rồi mình sẽ có
czech language
à à
3D crest
À mà đây sẽ có là
a tiếp theo
ô ô black-eyed i
tin tức là
cho đến object đến nay đi tiếp theo là
Asha
a boss đó đẻ xong
bài đang luôn
bộ nhông gửi cho
anh em mình tạo lại mình sẽ lưu lại
anh nghe này đang bị lỗ rồi kìa mắc này
đang có rồi à
Ừ thế nào ra sự đối xóa xóa smarty
anh xóa mày đang đi Sài Đăng
đúng rồi mình gõ sai
hay đúng không phải thay
có ai à Ok Ok
như thế phải đặt tên là ống chích hai nó
hợp lý hơn để hiểu nó liên quan theo
ngày thế thôi không sao không sợ
ờ ờ
như thế phải post của mình lại lỡ lên
trên mất rồi nếu trong trường hợp mà Mấy
ông muốn là an toàn bộ những thằng này
nó phải không phải là chăm thường hợp và
thằng nào Nhưng suốt được thành công như
này thằng nhìn xuất sau lỗi thì mày ông
nhá Ê mấy ông ngoại phải lại phải ngồi
xóa tay giống như tôi chẳng ạ Đấy là một
cái thứ hai là trong một vài trường hợp
bắt buộc cả bọn thêm phải thêm cùng nhau
chứ không có trường hợp mà tự nhiên họ
có này thêm được mà hài bị lỗi nhà trong
buồn cười không ạ thì ông sẽ có khái
niệm là cho sơ sinh cá hồi mà tôi dậy
quark thì mẹ cũng hiểu qua trái sân
nghĩa Nghe toàn bộ cái câu truy vấn đấy
mà mình sẽ đặt nó hết vào trong một cái
con nít là một cái một cái cái đẩy lên
đi một cái yêu cầu đẩy lên AK 1 trong và
hoàn toàn thể robot là quay ngược lại
mỗi khi mà có vấn đề gì đó ra xử ra sự
đây tôi sẽ có khái niệm và tôi sẽ có là
PB này
đấy Xong rồi Nếu mà thành công thì mình
sẽ dp
e ko bít là kiểu để xác nhận khi mà toàn
bộ đoạn này xong hết rồi Còn nếu mà có
vấn đề gì đó thì tôi sẽ là dp
robot để của anh ngược lại coi như là
thì mình sẽ không đẩy lên tôi sẽ tôi sẽ
trả xử lại ngồi xóa lại đi ạ sau đó thì
ở đây tôi mua rồi tôi tin sai nạn do sử
tôi không có thai được ạ tôi trong bến
xem nhé
tôi bác rồi Khi mà mới ông xem iPhone ở
đây không có vay có họ đẩy lên làm như
vậy Nãy nữa vì nó đang trong một cùng
một chai sẽ xinh rồi nghĩa là toàn bộ
Thằng này nó phải thành công hết thì là
mấy con nít nó mới đẩy lên còn không nó
sẽ quanh một dạng con ngựa không có cái
gì xảy ra đấy cả còn bây giờ tôi cho nó
lại này à
ok chưa đó xin ông xin ông đây Bố hôm
nay mình đã làm xong được thêm còn mày
quá Hơn Hai tiếng nữa rồi người cũng đã
xong
ra còn còn vẫn vẫn còn phải chỉnh các
những thứ đó là điều hướng quay trở lại
Xong rồi làm sửa xóa nữa nhưng mà sửa
xóa nữa là gần như cũng xong ở bên
emminh cũng tương đối xong rồi Vitamin
và mình vài bộ nữa mình sẽ làm cả bên A
ứng cử viên để lại hiển thị ra lắm ạ mày
dài quá vẫn Chắc là vẫn thể nợ buổi chia
sẻ vào hôm nay thứ
à Hôm nay thứ mấy à Có thứ 5 mà đúng
không Thôi tôi xin phép vào buổi thứ bảy
mình sẽ thư giãn nhiều hơn nha chị sẽ
tâm sự chia sẻ các thứ tuổi hồng thôi
nhé chứ hôm nay hơn hai tiếng thả lỏng
anh nha
mẹ mẹ mẹ ông chắc À hiểu được lá hôm nay
biết qua cả trái sơn các cụ thể vui rồi
nha bố mày tạm nghỉ nhé em ấy không nhé
ô